you know what Frank near broke his arm
when he tried to keep fighting yes you
too right yeah yeah cuz I remember the
crowd was booing like I was like you
guys you need to look at this yeah yeah
no that's a that's a that's me I'm gonna
tell you about that because that was a
funny story cuz like they are I hadn't
really there's one the first times I
think they trusted me with a
championship and he you know the arm
broke I heard it I saw it and I remember
you know I learned a lot I learned a lot
about my job right then because I what I
did is I backed off and I let the doctor
come in and examine them cuz like you
know sometimes when you're dealing with
an expert you don't want to clout the
way you're supposed to get out of the
way right like you don't go to the
mechanic and tell him what to do so I my
mind was thinking like that about the
doctor and so of course he comes in she
doesn't know what she's what she saw so
he misguides her and says I think he's
worried about this and then she's like
hey no nothing's wrong and I was like oh
man in my mind I was thinking it's been
great being here but I'm not going to be
doing this anymore I swear I was like in
my mind I was thinking that I was
thinking about how to get out of there
when they start throwing stuff oh
Miletich camp but maybe remember they're
over there wrestling with the Samoan you
guys trying to get in there people
screaming yeah that was that's his other
break it was an awful one yeah so then I
was thinking about that and then you
know but then you found it yeah you
saved me like I was thinking that my
retribution was gonna be like some kid
on the internet two weeks later like I
found out his arm was broken but you
found the spot and so then I was
watching the replay and I was like let's
take a look at this hold on hold on
what's that uh his arm I'm like that's a
broken arm
yeah that barn is broken look at that
watch it one more time when I had the
truck roll up uh-huh and then I went
into the Octagon and I remember saying
immediately like you guys need to watch
this like here we go let's play this
here we go that's a broken arm so I'm
gonna thank you for that right there
because I thought my path would have
been different
it was one of those things where I felt
an obligation to not just interview the
fighter but to explain to the entire
crowd like you gotta listen this is a I
know it looked crazy look crazy to me
too this is a broken arm like this guy's
fucked right now three places and Tim
thanked you afterwards for saving his
career because I said if you didn't stop
that fight and that became a compound
fracture fuck man
horrible things happen when the bone
breaks through his skin yeah I saw
happened I saw him afterwards and I said
man did you know your arm was broken and
he told me he goes yeah I know what was
your plan why are you trying to continue
so I knew I had a minute before the pain
really becomes lame yeah here is and
watch this part right snap right there I
mean that is 100% a double-double break
yeah both parts of the both bones of the
forearm snapped in half and it's an
unusual break because of where it is
yeah just shows you how fucking strong
Frank Mears armbars is how long-limbed
he is it was all so weird this house arm
went back into place and how young and
muscular I talked to the doctor they say
that happens sometimes with athletes the
muscles just put it right back yeah yeah
yeah well he had a play put in there man
forever it's still in there look at me
young full fresh-faced joe rogan man
that was okay young Frank looks huh huh
it's crazy he looks so lean and young
he's a big old giant dude now